okay today I'm going to talk to you
about radio waves I'm going to show you
how radio waves can be generated and
received and the different uses of radio
waves as well so first of all let's have
a look at radio waves in regards to the
rest of the electromagnetic spectrum so
just like the rest of the
electromagnetic spectrum radio waves are
transverse waves that transfer energy as
you can see compared to the rest of the
electromagnetic spectrum
they are the waves with the lowest
frequency that means the fewest waves
passing a point per second and also they
have the longest wavelength remember
wavelength is just simply the distance
between the peaks of two waves now just
like the rest of the waves in the
electromagnetic spectrum in a vacuum
they travel at the speed of light which
is around 300 million meters per second
so we're now gonna see how radio waves
can be generated so let's imagine we've
got a radio station that are
transmitting their show across the
nation now in order to broadcast that
signal first of all they need something
called a transmitter now a transmitter
is made by this this here is an
oscilloscope that just shows we have an
alternating current so in order to
generate this radio wave to transmit it
across the nation we need a transmitter
which is involves an alternating current
being supplied to an antenna and the
antenna antenna is made from a
conductive metal the alternating current
which is supplied to this transmitter
causes the electrons within the within
the transmitter to oscillate oscillate
oscillate means to move backwards and
forwards in a kind of consistent rhythm
now as that happens it causes the
generation of a radio wave which
transfers energy away from this
transmitter now let's imagine at the
other end we obviously need someone to
receive the signal in order to listen to
the radio show which has been broadcast
so at the other end we have a sin
the kind of setup but but instead of a
transmitter we have a receiver
essentially it's the opposite idea
instead of introducing an alternating
current to make electrons oscillate this
radio wave as it hits the receiver it
causes electrons to oscillate which are
in the receiver this in turn generates
an alternating current so this is how
someone received that radio signal which
then may be able to listen to this
particular broadcast over here so the
energy is being transferred from this
transmitter to this receiver and radio
waves can actually be transmitted
through the body without being absorbed
so what we're going to do now is we're
just going to have a quick look at a few
different uses of radio waves so number
one is long wave radio now these long
wave radios have free radio waves have
frequencies sorry not frequencies
wavelengths of 1 to 10 kilometers so the
distance between the peaks of two waves
are really really big between 1 and 10
kilometers now the reason why that they
could be received halfway around the
world from what from the transmitter
that it's that it started off with is
because these waves can Bend round the
Earth's curved curved surface so they're
excellent for transmitting information
over a very very long distance we also
have shortwave radio so again it's the
the radio waves are made in the exact
same way but only this time the waves
are shorter so the wave length is
shorter ten to a hundred meters instead
of one to one to ten kilometers now
these again can go receive the long
distance from the transmitter but for
different reasons it's because these are
actually reflected by the atmosphere
so these are both dealing with really
really long distances in order to
transfer data over a very short distance
we can use something called Bluetooth
now all Bluetooth is useful is for
transferring data wirelessly over a
short distance now the final one we're
going to look at is TV and FM radio so
compared to some of these for example
we're dealing with a much shorter
wavelength
now this FM SOI TV and FM radio
basically to get reception the truck of
the receiver needs to be in direct sight
of the transmitter because the signal
doesn't Bend or travel far through
buildings so it needs to be the receiver
needs to be in direct sight okay so that
basically guys is is an overview of
radio waves how they're generated and
received and the different uses thank
you